welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Loki season 2 revealed a
fascinating and confusing twist to he
remains plan his supposed successor for
the TVA Victor timley is not a variant
who spawned from a branch timeline at
least not right away he originated as a
doppelganger of himself that already
existed in sacred timeline history
before that Branch ever formed he was
planted there as a fail safe contingency
by someone in case he ever needed to be
activated I think many of us expected
more kangs to arrive as a result of
Sylvie breaking the sacred timeline like
the forums of the Kang Dynasty that we
saw in the Antman the was quantum Mania
mid- credit scene but that's not what
Victor timley is exactly Victor timley
is just a normal Candlestick maker from
19th century Chicago who always lived in
our history and just so happens to look
exactly like Jonathan major I can't be
the only one confused by this right so
let's break it down what exactly was he
remains fail safe plan when he died what
is his relationship with Victor timley
like he seems like the same person in a
way but not exactly and how did he
remains plan for a variant of himself to
live within the normal flow of our
history like how far back did he plan
this did he actually plan it or did
someone else plan it how many other
Jonathan majores are there in MCU
history all right I'm going to get into
it but please please please support new
rock stars by grabbing one of our Loki
inspired shirt from nerd r. shop I'm
wearing our M baseball te but we have a
new OB specific design that you are
going to love okay you may watch the
beginning of Loki season 2 episode 3 a
little confused because we find
ourselves in Chicago 1868 on the sacred
timeline it says sacred timeline in the
lower third so for something to be on
the sacred timeline it means that it was
part of the MCU history that we have
been watching since the beginning from
the 2008 Iron Man the 2012 Avengers the
events of Captain America the First
Avengers set in the early 40s the events
of Eternal set in ancient times Etc the
same America that produced Steve Rogers
the Stark family and Peter Parker the
same planet Earth that produced the
tribes of wakanda as we've known them
this is what the sacred timeline is it
is just normal uninterrupted history the
history we learned in lowkey season 1
episode 6 that was scripted by the Kang
variant he remains to exist that way
since Loki season 1 ended would still be
fracturing the sacred timeline into a
spectrum of branches where alternate
realities could be unfolding season 2
has added further Clarity to this
confusion by using these lower third
titles to differentiate when we are
seeing events that take place in the
sacr timeline or in a branch timeline
like Sylvie in 1982 Brockton Oklahoma
Branch timeline X5 AKA Brad in 1977
London sacred timeline apparently young
Victor timley making candles in 1868
Chicago sacred timeline but 189 93
World's Fair after Victor timley was
given the TVA guidebook now becomes a
branch timeline yes it makes sense that
rley are giving this boy this guide book
a future advanced technology would
create a branch timeline but what makes
less sense is that a kid who would grow
up to look exactly like Jonathan major
was already there in sacred timeline
history before anything happened to him
you could just shrug this off as
coincidence but no if they wanted Victor
timley to just be a random inventor just
influenced by TVA knowledge they could
have had anyone play him they had
Jonathan major play this role because
they wanted to imply that he is a a
variant the same way all of Major's
other variants from the quantum Mania
mid credit scene are and that this is
the origin of he who remains I think we
must conclude that young Victor timley
was planted here in history from a young
age perhaps as a baby back in season 1
episode 6 he remains told Loki and
Sylvie the origin story of the other
Kang variants eons ago before the TVA a
variant of myself lived on Earth in the
31st Century he was a scientist and he
discovered that there were universes
stack on top of his own but we should be
clear that he said a variant of myself
he doesn't say that he he remains came
from the 31st Century he said the others
came from the 31st Century he just kind
of implied that it took 31st Century
technology to begin to unlock all these
multiversal secrets and at the same time
the first king discovered it all the
other kings did too he remains doesn't
use his name but in the comics the 31st
century scientist is named Nathaniel
Richards and he's a descendant of Reed
Richards Mr Fantastic but even if the he
who remains we met in season 1 episode 6
didn't come from the the 31st Century if
he had his roots in the 19th century it
would still be a bit weird that they all
look identical someone would have had to
have planted him in the 1860s I think he
who remains the Kang variant who won the
multiversal war might have truly
originated as a guy named Victor timley
in the 1860s but that someone else must
have placed him there as a baby he was
someone else's contingency plan some
other Kang's Sleeper Cell and thank you
to better help for sponsoring this video
October is a stressful time of year
school has started the holidays are
approaching there's less Sun if you are
struggling with something don't force
yourself to Bear it alone get help from
a licensed therapist with better help
starting therapy can be hard the right
therapist for you may not be in your
area and some people struggle with the
face to-face interaction of therapy with
better help you can have your therapy
sessions as a phone call as a video chat
or even via messaging if you prefer that
whatever is the most comfortable version
of therapy for you just click the link
in the description and answer a few
questions about what you're looking for
from therapy and what your preferences
are better help will then match you with
a therapist from their Network that's
right for you and if you don't really
fit with that therapist which is a
common thing with therapy you can easily
switch to a therapist for no additional
cost without stressing about insurance
or who's in your network or anything
like that mental health is quite the
journey but it is an important one so
start your journey towards better mental
health click the link in the description
or visit betterhelp.com neww rockstars
to help support this Channel and get you
10% off your first month with better
help so back in the season one finale he
remains went on to tell Sylvia and Loki
that they had two options kill him and
unleash all of his variants or for them
to take over the TVA and keep the sacred
timeline intact as he had conceived it
Sylvie obviously takes the first option
but the more we look into it it just
sounds like he remains planned for
Sylvie to do that like he either wanted
her to do it or he knew that she was
destined to do it and he just wasn't in
control of that part of his Destiny in
this most recent episode of Loki Miss
minutes tells Ren Slayer he told me that
we need to put this package in that
window this was the plan he made when he
knew the end was near for him and she
later confirms that this was all part of
he remains plan to reinstate a variant
of himself back at the top of the TVA I
told you it's not my plan it's his plan
and quarian with our help he'll be all
he's meant to become but later Sylvie
says R slayer's interference with the
TVA guide book altered Victor timley
from a normal sacred timeline life if
you in the TVA hadn't messed with him
he'd have remained harmless and Slayer
set him on a path that he wasn't meant
for the only way this makes sense is
that he remains or some other Kang
variant took a Daniel Richard's variant
baby from another timeline and left him
with foster parents like Moses in a
basket back in the 1850s or 1860s of the
Sacred timeline now what makes of the
Sacred timeline is what he remain says
as a sacred timeline he decided that
this decision would not qualify as an
Nexus event it's just a thread woven
into the overall tapestry of the Sacred
timeline now this does open another
possibility would whoever planted young
Victor timely in the 1860s of the Sacred
timeline only plant one backup wouldn't
merely one backup once they were found
pose a huge risk to any contingency plan
that was formed it must be the case that
there are several dozens hundreds maybe
thousands of Victor Tim Le going by
other names on the sacred timeline
throughout history just living their
lives none of them amounting to anything
crazy but all of them dreaming of
something great when their sleeping
Minds dream walk into the eyes of sorld
conquerors and inventors and ready at a
moment's notice for a Divine hand to
drop a TVA guide book in their window
and change their Destiny perhaps we even
met some of these guys far ramut and
mortise Centurion Mr Griffin all the
kings in the arena of the Kang Dynasty
may have begun as Sleeper Cell kings
that the Rival Dynasty got to First Once
who initially lost the multiversal war
due to this one Victor timley or he
remains aligning himself with a ren
Slayer and taming aath together so what
have we learned about he's plan he is
just trying to restart the loop he knows
he is destined to die so he wants to
restart history so that his origin point
is restored as a young candlemaker named
Victor timley in 1860 Chicago who gets a
special gift of a book from the window
he wants to do his best to make sure
that the sacred timeline continuity
continues to loop back and play as it
always did so that hopefully one of the
other rival Kings can't slip in in his
place however he remains is in a Race
Against Time with the other kangs to try
to get this gospel in the hands of the
right Kang variant before they find the
others and lure them to their dark side
and what is he remains relationship with
Victor timley they are the same person
just a different points in their lives
one at the beginning and one at the end
however that beginning Point only begun
because some other freaking paranoid
baby kidnapping Kang committed a whole
bunch of future Amber Alerts and took
baby kangs and nestled them throughout
history one of them was Victor timley
subscribe to all three channels on the
new rockstars Network and you can
support us by grabing some merch at nerd
rot. shop follow me on all social
platforms at EA boss follow new
rockstars subscribe to new rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching
[Music]
bye
la